over the last year or two i've been
working very closely with famous
uk rapper crept from crept and conan
he's been doing some crazy things in the
property industry
and it's been great working with him and
in this exclusive interview
you're going to find out exactly what
he's been doing in business and property
so please welcome on winners on a
wednesday credit
where does your drive come from because
you are you know you're now doing big
things in property which is awesome
we've been working together a couple of
years
you've also got some crazy stuff which
we're not going to talk about
we're not going to talk about yeah but
you've got some crazy deals but in the
going on in the pipeline you're working
on in business
in invest investments um you know you're
obviously
very very successful in music as well
you'll want one of the one of the the
greatest
hip-hop artists you know with uh with
conan who's awesome
um where does that drive come from where
does that passion to win
come from um i don't know where the
passion comes from as in like
i don't know if it's me just thinking
about i'm always a future thinker i
always think about the future
and i feel like i'm always thinking
about what am i gonna leave behind for
the next generation or
you know and i'm i'm someone that always
thinks like worst case scenario like
what happens if i stop rapping or what
happens if my
i lost my voice and quite wrapping
anymore what happens if this happens or
what happens
i've always been just think so that
makes me just want to you know get up
and just do
so much different type of things you
know i'm saying and i love expansion
like i'm always about expansion it's
like yeah i can rap
black and i think i can rap and i'm sick
of rapping and i've got
but yeah i want to get into tv as well
now yeah you know we do
presenting stuff and it's like yeah i'm
up like i just always want to do that we
do radio let's
have our own radio show let's go and do
this and this
i'm always for expanding he's like yeah
let's do that i want to get into
property i want to get into this i'm
going to do that
it's interesting because a lot of people
as well i mean i coach a lot of
footballers and
and different people but they've kind of
got this mindset of they want to stay in
and people say stay in your lane stay in
your lane
yeah you don't agree with that no black
i don't think spread yourself too thin
but i do feel like there's always room
to
to grow and elevate yeah if you're a
winner at one thing if you're a winner
of football
you're a champion you can be a winner of
business you can be a winner property
100 what was it that made you reach out
to me
you just knew what you're talking about
bro like do you know you
you watch things or you see things and
you just think
not sure this person knows what they're
talking about or near this this person's
just winging it or
like you just knew what you talking
about and um
there was a specific video and
i think it was the when you went and
done the
rent to rent and i was just the way you
did it and i was just like no this guy's
actually
sick he's like no this guy's actually
sick like the way you speak to people
the way you hustled when you get things
done i was like no
you don't need to see this and i
remember posting a video like guys
check this out like and it was more one
of those ones that were like
look how he's done this like there's no
excuses and then even when i posted it
there's some people that got excuses in
the comments saying uh
but you can't but i'm just like bro the
haters in the comments
not even haters just you know there's
always people that are just like
negative or they find a reason not to do
anything yeah like
there's a big wide world out there to go
and make stuff happen
you know there's people that always find
excuses like nah
okay the kind of excuses to why they're
not winning yeah into why that's not
really possible why you can't do that
and then you've done it again
when you change the disguise and did the
same thing again i was just like what
are you going to say about that
only because he is and i'm saying you
can clearly see in the video they don't
have a clue
yeah yeah but anyway
what do you think the difference is
though between like a meaning a winning
mentality
and because in my opinion a winner would
see that i'm inspired
but a loser would see that and try and
come up with justification
a winner will celebrate someone else's
success i will be like you oh you're
winning awesome
a loser will say oh you're winning and
they'll try and justify as to why
i feel like winners attract everyone
this energy
like just by watching the video and
seeing that you're just a go-getter
yeah i can get on with you do you go i'm
saying like
you're a man that you'll see something
make something happen i'll get on
i feel like winners attract other
winners like yeah do you know what i
mean and i genuinely believe that and
people that don't have that mentality
like i feel like
you see it like if you feel like there's
an excuse of why you can't do that or
there's an excuse what he can do and you
can't do it you're just making an excuse
because i genuinely believe
anything's possible yeah and i feel like
winners believe
anything's possible yeah if i think i
can go
and do this i genuinely think i can do
this
and people think no you're mad how do
you think you can do that no because i
genuinely think i can do this
if i work hard and i do this x y z make
a plan and do this
why can't i do and some people just
think things are not realistic or i
think everything's possible like how can
someone from
here become a you know billionaire like
how it's possible
why do you think it can't happen to you
that i just genuinely don't understand
why people have self-doubt it's annoying
because it's like you
probably don't even know your own
potential bro when is your drive
to see other people wondering because
i'm like that
i think that's just something that i've
always been like it's just a trait of
mine
i love seeing people winning like i love
seeing other people
and i love being able to help pass some
knowledge and then see that person
yeah shine or win like i just lack that
feeling i don't know what it is
i've just always been a person that
loves helping people
yeah if i can yeah i'm saying um and
because i just feel like the universe
will repay you man and a lot of people
credit you for that like i saw where's
nelson where did his track
oh yeah i also know where his friends
have helped me with property as well
nice guy but um when he had his big hit
he was like he's actually crept behind
the scenes that was helping with that
track
trying through the ends like i'm batman
yeah
it's a wrap putty on a wrist and a
dashboard
yeah yeah and i don't want nothing even
temporary yeah do not mean it's not like
that's just how i am like he showed it
to me he's like can you hear my song
i've got a song that i made and
and he's like just let me know what you
think i heard it on that bro
yeah like behind the scenes you know i
probably can gassed it up did this and
then he had people like fighting for the
track labels was on here in this
everyone's on like what's this track
what's this
what's this talking about and yeah man
from there
he just took off but i like i had faith
in that song i told him this this song
is like banner from before i was even at
and then that song went on to do a
madness do you know what i'm saying
like i don't even want it's not like i
don't want i don't
want no credit for anything like it's
just like that's
his talent his song is everything you're
a chilled out down-to-earth guy
you've we've you've been out for dinners
with my family and stuff just chill
calm but then at the same time crushing
it in business
crushing getting investment in property
passionate and music helping people
you know keeping that humility up you
know i really respect that another thing
i respect about you as well
remember when you got me uh me and
amelia tickets to come down and see the
show
oh yeah just got out of concert with
crypt and conan from the revenger suite
album
man the way you can just hold a crowd
you know like energy yeah and you you
you kept saying that energy energy yeah
that's it energy
when like it's like switching when i'm
on that stage it's like something just
switches on in my mind and it's just
like
me yeah let's have fun that's true i
mean so anyone that's ever come to our
show they know that
our shows are just full of energy yeah
like vibes and energy that's it
like you're gonna come there in your
trainers and you're leaving your
trainers are gonna be [ __ ]
your hair's going to be sweated out and
that's that's your life which you know
i'm saying and you're going to be
wasted if you came here to drink
whatever it is you came to do
but wait that's that's that's our whole
eat bosses that you come there
watch with circles sing along sing your
heart out
emotional tears like there's you know i
mean like there's
it's a whole roller coaster of emotion
that our shows you get me so
to talk to me about um i know you've got
a lot of investments going on
businesses investments different things
um and you know me and you we like to
just talk about what we did
not what we're gonna do so right now
we're sat in one of your investment
properties
in liverpool talk me through because
when because i took you around a whole
bunch of houses you came up to the
office
we went we met up we went around a whole
bunch of different investment
opportunities
but it was this one where you were
smiling you were like i see the vision
what was it about this investment that
you what what vision did you see and
then i want you to talk through the
numbers talk to what happened
the reason why this one just made sense
was just because of
all the you know safeguarding effects
obviously you can't ever guarantee
anything
is going to go you know the way you want
it to but what you can do is get as much
information about a deal as you can
and go off of that and obviously we're
probably
it's always going to be a safe bet
regardless you know i mean like it's
like
aiming for here and you're not going to
fall here yeah you might fall here
yeah do you know i'm saying that's the
thing about property so it's like it's
just
trying to choose the the the
you know the swedish drop off yeah if
you're aiming for this it's not volatile
yes yeah did you get me crypto
um yeah so with this property
it was on um on auction for
43 000 and a couple of grand obviously
you take it to 45 000
with you know legals and whatnot so you
bought it for 43. 43 grand
which is crazy which is mad
because i remember buying it at 43
just in the state that it was in yeah
not long after someone was like i was
invited for
65. you haven't done it i haven't even
done anything yeah
do you remember i'm a good negotiator
right so when we bought it
well when you bought it i i helped you
buy it but when we got it
um it took ages to complete right
but because by the time you completed it
had gone up so much
already bro it was mad like yeah
um and that's another and another thing
it's like
that even even even though this was like
i thought was the best
you know out of the the deals that was
presented to me
like even the other ones are sick so
it's like you've got to know who you're
working with by the way
even what even the other deals were good
deals
oh yeah but you know this one just made
the most sense but i mean like you've
just got to be making sure that you're
you've got people that are presenting
deals that know you know
what they're talking about but with this
one with um
even you know when you you're doing your
fact checks and
you can see how much the properties are
going for yeah
on the street and there was a property
same
build spec yeah um
rooms and that was going for that went
that sold for 110
yeah 510 sorry that was valued at 110
000
and then it was like this house is 43
grand
got a quote from the builders saying it
was you know 30 grand max
to build legal 75k
investment houses sold
just a house just got valued you know
down road on the same road same spec
for 110 it was just like a no-brainer
yeah
like it just was a no-brainer and you
know
um obviously then you have the option
where if like do you want to sell it
refinance it people want to buy it as
well oh far
got enough for it and what did you say
when you when someone offered you 110
what did you say
so you bought the house for 43 grand you
spent 30 grand on it so
all in including legals and stamps
you're on about 75
then someone offers you 110 meaning
you're gonna make like 35 grand profit
but you just went now i'm good i want to
keep it and i don't fancy paying
the tax the capital gains tax exactly
so the best thing to do was refinance it
right and
you know refinancing you pull out 75
percent of the money
and that's on that equals about 80
something grand under the new valuation
so i put in 75 i'm pulling out like 80
grand
80 plus grand um so you're getting paid
to have the house
it's a free house so basically that [ __ ]
that should be
the title of this video me what's what
should we should put this out of the
video
how crap gets a free house yeah and
no but it it is essentially yeah it's a
free house because
you know put in 75 grand new valuation
110 grand refinanced it
got back 80 something grand
renting out each room so getting rental
income
yeah and the rent as well the money that
you get back for the record
look for the record a lot of property
investors they talk about a deal washing
its face
yeah meaning the rent covers the costs
the mortgage the council tax the bills
whatever
this property is not going to wash its
face this probably is going to actually
make cash flow it's going to be a cash
flow which is really important yeah
because the
you know uh the more the even of the
what the rooms are going for
around 350 400 350 400 per room
um the mortgages are you getting like a
one hundred and fifty pounds rent yeah
the mortgage is
200 and around 250 pounds
and then you've got bells so you're left
with about 500 pounds a month profit
yeah so you and it's a free house with
500
a month yeah after
you know you know all the expenses bills
mortgage whatever amazing and
so essentially like it's not costing me
anything
but you've made that happen because
number one you realized the property
because a lot of people are getting into
all different
types of investments but your actually
property
is going to outlive me yeah of course
right property
also even liverpool like people must
have thought you were mad behind in
liverpool
yeah they did but it it
the the reason why it was it made sense
in liverpool is because
for one everyone everywhere follows
london
liverpool they haven't
you know they haven't got with it yet so
yeah the only place liverpool is going
yeah absolutely what about is
christopher correct yeah do you remember
that newspaper article
about two months after you bought this
house that came out and it was saying
liverpool's about to crash oh my god do
you remember yeah and you sent it to me
and you went
yo mentor
should i be concerned do you remember
that happening because i didn't
understand why i was
crashing when it hasn't caught up with
london and yeah well they were saying
it hasn't it hasn't started this
movement yet but and i i did a whole
video about that i was like dude here's
my response video
i was like houses in liverpool are not
about to crash because as you just said
everyone follows london
they're bombed out they're only going up
and this area of liverpool it's not the
greatest area
it's a little you can tell by walking
out that's why you've got to be careful
with what you're reading and who
are listening to as well yeah cause that
could have potentially
made me think ah do you know what i mean
by just knowing the fact that
you know how on the basis of how
the property market moves yeah and
knowing that liverpool hasn't
but the newspapers are often wrong
i mean one you know for many other
reasons
we won't go there but the thing is
warren buffett says when people are
scared you should be greedy when people
are greedy you should be scared
through the pandemic everybody's scared
everyone's freaking out
you're investing your money your
hard-earned money into properties
yeah it's going up in value you're
getting tenants
you know which is which is great also
you bought the property december
2020 refurbing everything took about
four or five months
and everything was strategic because you
knew
that in june i.e next month
you knew that something's going on
what's happening next month
in this area to houses oh my god
article four article four and what does
that mean
no more hmos right so they're gonna stop
hmos
um in liverpool yeah for good
for good so as from next month you
cannot buy a property
and turn it into a hmo without getting
planning permission which will probably
be refused
but it for you how's that going to
affect you
it's not because you're going to get the
grandfather rights exactly
she's just amazing and it's so good it's
so smart the last
one of the last properties to have to be
able to do hmo
yeah it probably will though although i
think there's a lot of my students
probably
just jumping in trying to get their
stuff sorted jumping in
so so not only has the property gone
from 43 to 110 and you're renting out
and making
a good profit it's a free house but over
the next few years there's regeneration
article 4's coming in next month which
is going to push the value of the houses
up which is just credible
so um so you're not just a rapper you're
kind of a pretty smart rapper
which is great
what what are your what are your plans
within property for the future
wait wait wait what do you want to you
know what do you want to do
um to be honest i want to start you know
doing big builds and
you know just bigger deals and stuff i
feel like
you know it's all good doing you know
the house of hmos this stuff and for
but i feel like you get a lot more
out of it when you do bigger deals
building apartments yeah complexes yeah
and then and you've been watching my
stuff closely and and i said to you
let's do this as a test
and then once we do this we can slowly
build up and up and up
this has gone well so you want to stop
building yeah man
definitely like on a much bigger scale
yeah yeah what has the process
and i can't take credit because we've
had an amazing team mark can't write the
builder
um net now rooms renting their body up
great team
but what's the experience being like
from this your team bro
a1 yeah you can't see no no like
seriously so much things that you
spotted um
decided and and presented to me like
crap
look i think we should do that i think
we should do that i think we should do
that i think we should do that
and i was like yeah it makes sense
everything just made sense and i was
like yeah
you know what i mean i want to trust you
and and and your opinion means a lot to
me as you know
so when you did come to me with things
that you wanted to change
and ideas i i went with it and
i can smash that apart bro yeah
yeah everything made sense in it and it
works and also throughout all this
you have become a father yes which is
awesome in fact i think i think i was
one of the very first people you told
actually because you told me yeah
i told you before like way before i even
said anything publicly
yeah yeah and and um now you've got
beautiful little girl
yeah which is which is awesome what
what's that what's it like being a dad
that's crazy it changes your whole
perspective on life and stuff and that's
another reason that you know i'm even
more driven to get into property because
it's like
that's one thing i know i'll be able to
pass down i might not be able to pass
down my talent
she might not be into music or she might
not be able to do music or sing but one
thing you can pass down is
is bricks and mortar so yeah that's
another you know
motivation for me as well so yeah well
man
i've got a lot of respect for you as a
person as a businessman as an investor
very smart investor as well because you
know you you've
you saw a lot of properties you had a
lot of choice um also mad respect to you
as well because when we first met
which i think when did you first come
down to the office it was like back into
2019
yeah and just after that that's when i
had
um my my hate train as you call it yeah
you know and i just really respect you
kind of just standing with me through
that because a lot of people didn't
as you know as i know yeah 100 yeah you
know it is i
i get it as well like i know i really
know about this thing called the hatred
it's like once
you know a few people start saying
something everybody just wants to run
and start saying the same thing
which i mean we've experienced it as
well so seeing seeing
that happen in review it didn't phase or
make me change the decision i'm a
grown-ass man and i know
you know wrong from right and i know you
know if someone knows what they're
talking about if someone doesn't know
what they're talking about
and you do bro like you know i mean like
everything's backed up with facts and
evidence
and for me it's just like some people
are some people just aren't so lazy they
can't even be asked to go and
even you know do their own research on
things and things that you're saying
like
is what he's saying is our lives you
know when you're explaining how the
process of certain things or is he lying
about this is
like he isn't you know i'm saying no
one's
you know you know people are blaming
trying to blame you for stuff
when it's like we're all grown adults we
all can make our own decisions and
do you know what i'm saying like
everything's you know
it's like what what i felt like was
happening was people
was i don't know you know probably
making decisions based on what they're
learning from you
and if something didn't go right at the
start or go right
they just they're just saying that's
your fault when just
the world of work just does not work
like that you know there's there's
a set way of how things work and nothing
is gonna
you know 100 gonna you know just be a
smooth sailing
situation in any in any case like if you
get into business your
entrepreneur whatever it is that you do
nothing's muslim things always go wrong
i can follow the exact same you know
method as this person and
it just doesn't go right for me i can
use the exact same builders
as you did yeah and that builder can
turn around and say uh or have a bad day
or say i'm not in the mood today or
quit do this i'll do do that and what am
i meant to
say that's your fault because no it's
this this is
that that works but as long as what
you're saying is
is honest and true and and that's it and
i can make my own decision
based on that so i'm not really here
trying to hear you know
a hate train of stuff yeah if i listen
to that now i remember as well because
we went out we were in uh in costa cafe
and a little bit
and i had the first time ever because
people were sensitive online
the first time ever it's never happened
before someone came up to me to my face
i was like oh you're that
you're that guy with all the bad press
and blah blah blah and i was like i was
thinking down man i'm sat here with you
you know i'm thinking what are you gonna
be thinking about this it's crazy
i'm pretty sure you told him to suck his
mama or something yeah no did you know
it wasn't
no he just started he just started
getting mad irate in it like all right
stop [ __ ] start just and it just
started escalating a bit and it was more
like bro
chill out bro yeah yeah i'm saying that
okay cool
you've got your opinion but you're
getting a bit too right now so just
chill out in it so i just started to
[ __ ]
okay i'm glad you had there to suck his
mom up
but but in all seriousness through that
time i mean that's past now that's
history for me
but like through that blip i just really
appreciate your support and everything
um and um i'm well pleased with what's
happened with this house with some of
your other things that you've got going
on in the pipeline what's been the
highlight for you we just over the last
year or two
on a um on the on the property side the
highlights i'm gonna say like
obviously i haven't done the refinancing
thing yeah
that that that was a new side to
property obviously
um because that obviously i'm
you're not having capital you can invest
in property and you're not thinking
about how i'm going to get back this day
just investing less investing
but you know going through the process
of the you know refinancing
and doing it in that way in this
specific explain that to me because
when we met you were already an investor
you were already an accomplished
business person you were already very
successful in music and stuff
but i was trying to help you do it more
creative and the reason i kind of came
on and sort of
changing the ropes was to how you could
scale it faster bigger so
from for me it was about getting into
probably just gotta have loads of
capital in it yeah
and then something was just like nah
this guy this is
this isn't the way bro and then i just
remember um
you know i was watching a few of your
videos and stuff and i was like
oh so
then that's when i started learning
about refinancing
you know buying getting it valued
refinancing pulling the money out yeah
doing like that process
yeah um yeah it is
obviously in a property you put buy to
let
25 deposit is is is what you
need so obviously because i bought this
cash
and um paid for the
refurb cash as well um
you would get 75 back of the new value
of the new value sure so you like push
the value up
yeah so you buy the property yes the
value up with the refund
and that new valuation is what you then
yeah you know you get a mortgage on got
you
and when you pull that money out or if
you or even if you pull out that money
and some
and some do you pay tax on that money
you don't pay no taxes how come because
it's seen
as a debt right and you can't pay tax on
the property tax on the debt so the
money that you put out
is your money but it's considered a debt
i'm wondering
when are you going to set up your own
property training course that's what i'm
thinking
i'll leave that one to you
final question of all the things that
you're doing right now
your music your your foundation
inspiring kids property business
what do you want to be remembered for if
i'm honest i
i i really want to leave a strong real
estate portfolio behind me
yeah like like that's that's really
important
that's awesome bro well it's been an
honor helping you on the real estate
side of things for sure
um appreciate everything you've done as
a friend
and and working with being awesome so
i'm sure we'll do another video in 12
months time
and share some of the other bigger deals
that we're working on yeah exactly
appreciate you man like genuinely your
team sick team
like be like everybody that's just even
been
you know on this journey with us
awesome bro pleasure man appreciate it
so there you have it guys
winners on a wednesday would you believe
it if you want to do the same
if you want to grow your portfolio you
know what you need to do subscribe to
the channel baby
subscribe to the channel smash like i
give
so much free training away as well you
can check out the link in the
description
come down to a training program free on
the house if you enjoyed it
like like like share this video far and
wide and i'll see you guys
next time